you all right oh my god hey jim
not now toby my god get the hell out of
here idiot what did i do
hey jim come here for a second can you
answer me something
as as a true eagles fan oh boy
how do you live with a franchise this
bad on a wing and a prayer
mostly all right whatever you say uh
listen while i have you here with toby
i need to give you a formal warning
about your job performance
a formal warning it's actually not a
joke
i know how you spend your time here i
know how little you care about your job
and honestly if you spend as much time
selling as you do goofing around with
dwight and hanging out at reception
we wouldn't be having this conversation
i'm sorry is this because i talked to
wallace about your website because i
really didn't mean to go
over your head this has nothing to do
with that all right
i always appreciate constructive
criticism about my job performance
i thrive on it i'm sorry then do you
mind explaining it a little better cause
i'm not sure what's really
don't get all defensive all right it's
just a warning
if you want the details toby can provide
you take it easy all right
i'd say all the goofing around at pam's
desk and
and hanging out with pam just finally
caught up to him
you know with pam
hey toby hey jim all right man oh really
good
hey you hey welcome back oh is that like
a new thing or
no i'm sorry that's cool no it's nothing
let's just
all right good to be back okay all right
all right sorry
sorry about that that was what
nothing
hey hey i got you one oh wow thank you
yeah i'm just gonna grab some chips you
want some no thanks uh we're still
having lunch today right
i guess
how dare you
hey toby what's this huh
i just want to remind everyone about the
company rules involving pda
or public displays of affection yes uh
some people in the office have
complained
oh without some other people engaging in
pda and
you know just want to remind it's not
appropriate to to do that
this is about me and jan in my office
because i will have you know that that
was consensual
what we did has nothing to do with you
or anyone here i don't think
anyone heard anything we were very
discreet
and and i most people had left by that
point so i don't
i don't think it's any of your business
so what i think you should do
is roll up the memo real tight okay hey
look the memo was not about
you for the record i have never been
involved with anyone at work in any
capacity
all right everyone look all right the
complaint was
about jim and pam so
no way what you guys are together
um yep
yes we are wow wow
awesome to the two of you
yes yes toby was this your fun little
way of congratulating us
yes oh okay
oh jim hey hey toby there's this female
uh a stenographer at the courthouse no
one looks exactly like you that's
incredible yeah you know it's on camera
you know what's crazy i can't reconnect
with you right now
it's kind of too bad we're not coming
into work tomorrow why
i bet michael had some elaborate theme
party planned like scrambled eggs
saturday
i'm like hey everyone let's get your
boss laid saturday
i have an announcement uh to make
i am moving to costa rica
thought about it for a long time now
and i'm finally gonna do it
so i'm just gonna hop the fence and jog
home now
you